cuando practican patear un balón
regatean y pasan hasta perfeccionar cada
movimiento estas jóvenes no están
simplemente jugando al fútbol están
luchando contra los estereotipos de
género porque aquí en la villa 31 La
Barriada más antigua de Buenos Aires el
campo de fútbol ha sido durante mucho
tiempo un mundo de hombres
cuando era chiquita o sea los varones no
te dejaban jugar porque los hombres eran
muy machistas y no no dejaban que las
mujeres jugaran el deporte el fútbol
para mí no tiene género ya que todos
somos capaces no pero a veces al decirte
cosas o al no compartir la cancha o
sacarte la pelota no no puede jugar al
fútbol Cómo estás hacer que el fútbol
sea accesible para todos es la misión de
Mónica Santos desde hace 15 años esta
antigua jugadora de fútbol lucha para
que este campo situado en el corazón de
un barrio desfavorecido se utilice para
la práctica de las mujeres dos veces por
semana para ella ocupar este espacio es
un primer paso para a más puertas a las
mujeres
los cambios se empiezan ahí y no a
partir de recuperar una autoestima a
partir de percibir un cuerpo como fuerte
en contra de lo que nos dijeron
históricamente No que no puede ser
agresiva que tenés que hacer sumisa
pensando nada más que tu vida focalizada
hacia la maternidad el fútbol los ayudó
a nosotras un montón a desarmar esos
prejuicios esos argumentos
constanza es la prueba viviente de que
la teoría de Santos funciona tras años
jugando en el campo constanza convirtió
su pasión en un trabajo
y ahora sí ahora con 31 años se gana la
vida como entrenadora de fútbol cambio
un montón de mi vida Me formó como
persona
me guío a romper patrones familiares y
hoy en día me siento libre tomo mis
decisiones propias a través del fútbol
algunas mujeres argentinas han
encontrado su vocación otras han
encontrado una comunidad una forma de
brillar como equipo